this is a production of cornell
university
um as don mentioned i was really lucky
in that i got to
do part of my dream award
uh i started in january and things only
started
getting interesting when covet was
starting to get interesting
but i did manage to learn a lot from
coffee and i just want to share
some of that with you um today
so
this was my initial plan was my husband
and i were going to
travel down to mexico
and hopefully meet some farmers who are
growing organic
coffee organic coffee is um
one of the biggest growing areas of
coffee in in terms of the market share
that it has and the mexican farmers have
been doing it
for many years and they are probably the
most successful organic coffee growers
so i wanted to go and meet them and see
what i could learn from them
and like i said just as we were getting
to the southern part of mexico
in chiapas covered with cerny get
interesting
the original plan was that we were going
to travel to colombia
to meet up with some organic growers
there as well
and then we managed to make some
contacts in peru so we were hoping to
get
to peru as well but what ended up
happening was
we drove all the way down to tapachula
which is down in the south
very close to guatemala and on march
12th we decided you know what
it's getting kind of weird uh mexican
government was starting to shut down
certain institutions and
things like museums and universities
were starting to close and we didn't
want to
get stuck so we decided to head back to
the states
and a couple of days later
we were spending the night with a friend
in san luis potosi and we heard that the
colombian border had shut down and they
weren't taking
any travelers anymore to try to keep the
virus under control so
we had rented out our ithaca house we
couldn't come back here
we couldn't get to colombia which was
the initial plan
so we decided well let's just spend
some time with my sister in rural
sinaloa because
that sounded like a safer option than
coming back to upstate new york given
kobe so this is a picture of our car
in um in
a little town called amburgo in
chiapas which is a couple of kilometers
north of
of guatemala so
fortunately before all of this i took
advantage of the smart
program which is hosted in the dyson
school
and it's a class that happens over
winter break
where as the name implies student-led
multi-disciplinary research teams come
together
and basically do a consulting
project for an agribusiness in
what they call a developing economy and
um with my former office mate marie
swetzler who is a cornell grad
we organized a trip down there because
we thought oh we can bring
relatively low cost easy soil testing
um a little soil package that we put
together we would do
a ph test and we would do an active
carbon test and we would talk to the
farmers about how
their management of the farms could
impact
their soil quality and
we met a lovely organization
um but sorry that skipped um
but we we learned a lot more than than
we were able to give back to them
and this
experience inspired my dreary trip in
that i wanted to
fully grasp what it is that is limiting
coffee farmers
nowadays so in case um
people don't know i'm gonna give a
little crash course in what coffee is
in the horticultural sense of the crop
so most of what we know as coffee is a
species called kofia arabica
which is pictured here next to my very
tall husband and as you can see
it can grow to be a pretty large bush it
grows up to
around nine meters in the wild it's
originally from the highlands
of ethiopia where it is a an understory
shrub so it grows in pretty dense
forests
it doesn't like it too warm and it
doesn't like it too cold
so the temperature ideals range between
15 and 24 degrees celsius it definitely
cannot stand any frost
and this makes it ideal to grow in the
highlands in the tropics
um it's also really tied to
precipitation
in terms of flowering and
um an interesting fact it's an aloe
tetraploid which means that it has
it the species arose as a hybridization
event between
coffea canefera which is another coffee
crop that we actually consume
and coffee euglenoides which is not a
crop
and the result kofi arabica
kept two complete copies of both of
those genomes
um it is the only polyploid species in
the genus
it is self-pollinating which makes it
relatively easy
to propagate and each flower will
produce a droop
which is what we call the coffee cherry
and then those have
usually have two seeds which is what we
call the coffee beans and that's what
most people are familiar with it's just
a very slow crop to grow so most farmers
will start their plants from seed
and it'll take them six months between
sowing to actually transplanting them in
the field
you won't get a first harvest until two
years after
and then each year after that you'll get
an inflorescence which takes nine months
to develop into a fully mature seed
so it is it is actually a really slowly
developing crop and it also means that
as a farmer you need to take care of
these seeds
for a really long time before you can
harvest them
each plant can live around 20 years but
more intensive
management styles will place plants
around every eight to ten years
so like i said coffee grows in the
tropics because of it
the ideal temperature ranges
and brazil is the only country that can
afford to grow it on flat land
so they have these huge extensions of
perfect altitude perfect temperature
and this has allowed them to have
enormous plantations that are completely
mechanized and completely
everything is done in a really
technological way so you see
monocultures
all the same variety everything is
handled in a very intensive way
but as you can see in the image to the
left that also leads to
harvesting that isn't even so you are
harvesting green beans you're harvesting
red beans and the
ripeness of those beans is going to be
completely different
and that's why colombian coffee became
so famous
because the topography that the rest of
latin america has which is these
really rough mountains allows for the
right elevation for coffee to grow but
it doesn't allow for mechanization so
you can't have mechanical picking here
everything has to be done by hand and
what the latin american countries did is
they capitalized on what would have
otherwise been
a disadvantage right so instead of
having these
very efficient plantations as they do in
brazil what these countries did was
promote the quality of their coffee
however as i mentioned everything has to
be done by hand so
labor is incredibly important in
coffee production and these are actual
pictures
of last year's harvest in colombia from
this
um great article but i just want to
point out that
the ripeness of the cherries is very
even what you can see in the basket in
the top left
is that all the beans are red and ripe
and there's actually some farms where
the pickers will
paint their thumb nails red so that they
can match up
the thumbnails to the cherries that
they're picking
so this is the organization that we
worked with through the smart programs
their name is federacion campesina del
cauca
and they are a
second tier organization that makes up
around 700 member families
they are all small holders which means
that they
have relatively small farms the average
farm size
in this organization is around maybe
three acres
or 1.5 hectares something like that
they promote organic coffee as part of
their mission to improve the livelihood
of local farmers
and they're just they're a wonderful
group and that they have really tried to
do
all of it they try to work on the
growing part of it on the quality part
of it on the marketing
maybe even started roasting their own
coffee
and part of the the biggest lesson that
i got from them
is that coffee growers they know what
they're doing they know how to manage
their farms and they know
how to make the right decisions for
their farms the one thing that they do
not have
access to is the market side of it
so they do have a lot of other
challenges and
climate change is just exacerbating all
of them and it is incredible to see
how aware these farmers are of climate
change
there isn't a single farmer i've ever
talked to who doesn't mention climate
change as the biggest challenge they
have
and one of the consequences of this is
that the coffee berry borer which is
this tiny little beetle
um it likes hot temperatures and it
benefits
from hotter years in that it manages to
produce more and more offspring and have
basically it accelerates its life cycle
so you have more generations happening
within
a particular time frame and this is a
picture of
my hand holding a bean that was infested
with them
um their life cycle is very interesting
that they very
infrequently mate most of their
reproduction happens through
parasitogenesis so the females will
leave the infected being only for a very
short period of time
and will find an uninfected being and
they bore their
way into it lay eggs and then die inside
the bean
the picture on the right here is a trap
where you have soapy water in the bottom
of this bottle and then in the little
vial you have
a mixture of ethanol and methanol which
attracts them
and they're not very smart they just
fall in there and die
but the they use these traps to keep
track of the population
sizes and the only way to manage this
bug really
is cultural so you have to pick every
single bean
that is in the farm if you let any beans
fall to the ground they will just become
breeding grounds for new bugs
because they spend such a short amount
of time outside of the bean
spraying for them is not really an
option
so unless your neighbors and everyone in
your region is working
together to control this bug it can
really become a problem
if people leave
ripe beans just lying around for them to
infest
another huge issue that coffee growers
have is coffee
leaf rust which is a fungus it is a
obligate um oh my god for another word
they need a living tissue to reproduce
so they will infect the underside of the
leaves
and they create these little spots that
look like rust hence the name
and they can propagate ridiculously long
distances and it's really hard to
understand what is
exactly going to cause an outbreak of
rest so it's very hard to control
um there were two particular cases that
kind of stand out
in the history of coffee rust in latin
america
in 2008 it devastated colombia and then
in 2011
to 2012 it devastated central america
and they think that
the patterns kind of match up with
greater
metal meteorological patterns so they
think that el nino
fluctuations might be involved in
spreading the spores throughout
the whole region there's also
a lot of influence on the changes
between daylight and nighttime
temperatures
and relative humidity so unfortunately
climate change is just exacerbating the
disease pressure on coffee plants and a
lot of what
um conventional coffee plants
coffee plantations will have is
susceptible varieties
and as you can see on the right what
ends up happening
is when you have a really bad
infestation your plants lose all their
leaves
they don't necessarily die from it but
your crop is definitely affected for the
rest of the year
working with the fct i learned though
that the biggest problem
that coffee growers have is the
fluctuations in the coffee price
because most of the coffee in the world
is still
being sold through the stock exchange
and that's terribly unfortunate because
the stock exchange doesn't really care
about the weather
or how good the production was in one
place versus another so
because of all the financial tools that
people use
trading and futures and all sorts of
speculation
the price that coffee growers get for
their crop is incredibly volatile and
it's really hard for them to plan
for the next year so this graph is
showing
the prices in dollars per pound that
um people are trading coffee at the
stock
exchange obviously the farmers get a
fraction of this and depending on who
they sell their coffee to
that fraction can be anywhere from 60
of this price to 90 is the highest that
i ever heard um
and as you can see the price increased a
little bit during 2012
after the coffee leaf rest devastated
central america
but other than that it just keeps
getting lower and lower
so organizations such as fair trade have
come together and said
all right we need to guarantee these
farmers at least a minimum price that
will cover
their production costs and they agreed
on a dollar
40 as the fair trade minimum however
that only applies to farmers that
can afford to sell their coffee to
somebody who
recognizes that they are following the
fair trade
guidelines and they have to be certified
and certifications come at their own
cost
to farmers if you sell organic fair
trade certified coffee then you have
a price of 1.70 which is a little bit
better
but then you also need to have access to
somebody who will buy your coffee as
such
so ultimately it comes down to financial
sustainability if a coffee farmer is not
making ends meet at the end of the year
they might be viable for a couple of
more years but they can't keep it up in
the long term
so um miguel gomez at the dyson school
and his team have been working on what
does it actually cost
to produce coffee because data are
just ridiculously hard to come up come
come up with in the first place but also
um compare between different systems in
different regions
so they teamed up with fair trade and
the atkinson center and did this
beautiful project where they tracked
how much does it cost to produce a pound
of coffee
and they teamed up with these four
organizations
one was in mexico in honduras in
colombia which happens to be the fcc the
organization i worked with
and then one in peru and between them
they gathered 2
400 members that their average farm size
was 3.5 hectares so that's
somewhere around 8 acres
this represents a total volume of more
than 16 million pounds which is a lot of
coffee
most of it is certified fair trade and
most of it is organic so these farmers
actually have access to what we would
consider the higher
end of the coffee price
however what this study found was that
none of these farmers are making enough
money to make their farms viable in the
long term
this graph shows the cost of coffee
production
separated from in in different
categories
so the variable costs are the things
that you don't necessarily have to do
every time
things like you might fertilize this
year but not next year
or you may have to invest more in
pesticides
the fixed costs are the things that
happen every year things like taxes
labor for the harvest the depreciation
cost
includes the cost of okay so you buy a
tractor this year and then
it wears and tears over a year so it
loses value
and then the total costs
account for how much it costs to
establish
the coffee farm in the in the in the
first place how much it costs to buy
new seeds things like that that don't
necessarily
happen all the time but that ultimately
make
make part of your of your agricultural
business
and then the little red dot in the
middle is the farm gate price that these
coffee growers are getting so even
though
most of these people were selling their
coffee as fair trade certified which
would guarantee them that 1.40 minimum
they are not getting that they are
getting a ridiculously lower price
so part of this experience that i've had
with coffee
is meeting all of these small holder
farmers
and around the world we're talking about
25 million people who
farm less than 10 hectares and
usually fall below the poverty line
but many of them have this incredibly
strong attachment to their land and
their culture they've been farming
coffee for generations
um many can trace their coffee ancestry
back to like the 1800s at least the
people i've spoken to in colombia
so losing their coffee business
is more than just losing their cash crop
it's very tied to their identity
and because they are farmers they're
also growing their own food so even
though you don't necessarily put a value
on the additional crops that you have
you're still feeding your family off of
that so the value that is
in a way not um monetized
is is incredible and it's at risk of
being lost
so um i used part of the time on the
drear to participate in this
workshop that was organized by the
university of wagnerhead
in collaboration with siat which is a
center for
international tropical agriculture based
in kali colombia
and as you can see many of you might
recognize alyssa pritz and marie
swetzland who are cornelians
they brought together these coffee
researchers from
around the world with different
expertise on
pests and on marketing and on
agroforestry systems and they wanted to
diagnose what is going on with coffee
growing and what is going to happen
to all of these people and all these
um landscapes that are changing
and we identified six
main trends and research needs
um for the next decade
um so the first thing that we're seeing
is that
people are substituting their
traditional varieties because like i
said traditional varieties are very
susceptible to rust
so if you can have a resistant variety
you are going to simplify
your production costs but also it's
going to make your whole farm a little
bit
more resilient there's also a big push
towards intensification because
if you can't reduce your costs you have
to increase your yields
to be to keep financially sustainable
there's also a lot of land abandonment
and land use substitution
so you've probably all heard about the
south american
the central american migrations that are
happening people are
afraid and there's a lot of violence
there's very
very few economic opportunities so
people are leaving
their land in the case of colombia
there's huge pressure from
illegal crops on the same lands that
coffee now
occupies there's also been a lot of
expansion of range
into higher elevations because of
climate change so as temperatures get
higher
people are pushing higher higher up the
mountains threatening
native forests there is also a couple of
countries that had traditionally banned
the growing of coffee
coneferra known as robusta because it's
traditionally known as lower quality
coffee
but they are now starting to allow it
and there's also a lot of urbanization
as
some of these communities get more
wealthy people start leaving the
countryside for the city they decide
to build houses on their farms and so
all of this land is being lost
this problem is particularly bad in
costa rica
i'm going to focus on these three trends
just because
i saw them during my junior trip
um and because i think they're the more
general ones
to the whole of latin america so
there's a huge problem with traditional
coffee varieties and that they are
a genetic bottleneck
and there's absolutely no disease
resistance genes in them so
most of what we know as
at least arabica coffee comes from the
few plants
that the europeans back in the
probably 1600s
took from yemen and started bringing to
their colonies
in particular to indonesia and to it
with ceylon
and that in itself is already a
bottleneck but then the plants that got
to latin america
are just a substitute of that
so all of the varieties that are now
grown
throughout all of latin america come
basically
from the typica and the bourbon
and even though there are a handful of
other and people usually
will associate the diversity in the bean
sizes and colors which you can see in
the left hand side
with genetic diversity the truth is that
these varieties are
very similar to each other so
there's been a huge push for
promoting these varieties called
katimores and sarchimores
because they come from a wild hybrid
that was found
years ago decades ago in indonesia
in an island called timur which is a
hybrid between kofia arabica
and kofia kanaphara and that hybrid
actually has disease resistance genes
against
coffee leaf rest so people have been
introgressing those genes
back into the more culturally acceptable
coffee varieties
but there's been a lot of pushback
because they are associated with lower
quality products
so like i mentioned before there was a
big uh leaf rust outbreak
in colombia in 2008
where 80 of the coffee was susceptible
to rust
and since then the federation of coffee
growers in colombia has been pushing
really hard
to get people to plant resistant
varieties to the point where in 2018
80 of the coffee in columbia was
resistant to rust
so at least that problem has been kind
of taken care of
however in speaking with the farmers
i've learned that
they don't particularly oops they don't
particularly like
growing these resistant varieties
because they have other characteristics
they're harder to pick
um the beans feel different the sizes
are different
and there's this myth that the quality
is inferior
i do want to take a second to um talk
about
the national coffee grove federation in
colombia it's basically it started as a
union of coffee growers
and i want to mention them because
they are the only example i know of
where there's a strong institution that
is taking care of coffee growers in the
region
and you can probably recognize the logo
they did a incredible marketing campaign
back in the
80s where something like 90 percent of
people in europe will recognize the logo
as a high quality product
and the image in the left is an actual
actor who's this is his real-time
job he is juan valdez he impersonates
this
colombian coffee grower and he carries
his meal around
this is at the um
the red carpet party that they held for
a movie
a while ago called bruce almighty where
he actually
requests coffee grown in the mountains
of colombia from juan valdez
but the reason i bring it up is because
it's
probably the most successful marketing
campaign for
an agricultural product that doesn't yet
have any added
value like colombian coffee is green
beans it's not even roasted
and yet everyone everywhere recognizes
it as a high quality product
in fact i learned recently that in 2005
it was the first
non-european product to be granted
a protected denomination of origin
so there's essentially champagne and
parmesan cheese
and then there's colombian coffee which
is really impressive
so there's been another trend in how
coffee is grown uh it used to be that
coffee was grown
in the understory of a forest that's
where the coffee plants come from
and so you can have what is known as
rustic coffee where you just have an
intact forest that you just grow a
couple of coffee plants on the bottom of
but it's there's been a strong push
towards intensification which is on the
on the lower end of this figure
where you basically have no shade or
just a few
shade trees
and this comes in part because if you're
in the
mountains usually you have a lot of rain
so your plants are going to be light
limited
and if you want to increase your yields
the best thing you can do is increase
the light
access of your plants however
the more shade you have the more
ecosystem services that you have so for
instance there's good data that
if you have more birds you're going to
have less coffee bean borer pressure
if you have more shade it's going to
reduce the fluctuations in temperature
and so the leaf rust is going to hit
your coffee less
hard you can also have additional
benefits of nitrogen fixation depending
on the trees that you use
of different soil quality different
nutrient cycling
so there's there's a really strong push
especially from academic circles for
people to grow coffee under some sort of
um agroforest polyculture system
however the um
shift towards growing robusta coffee is
doing the opposite it's pushing for
monocultures because
robusta is a really uh hearty plant
it is completely resistant to breast it
can take harsh conditions it can take
high temperatures
and exposure and it yields
something like twice as much as an
arabica crop
it also has higher caffeine so it's
preferred
for um processed coffee beverages
so your pre-made starbucks coffee
and your four loco and your five hour
energy drink all of those
caffeine products probably come from
robusta
so when we were in mexico in the
southern part of chiapas we met up with
this
lovely professor at ekosur which is the
their regional university
his name is juan barrera and he works on
biological control
of coffee bean borer in robusta
plantations
and one of the things that he showed us
was
the the change so you go from these
beautiful forests to a completely
exposed field with these
enormous robusta plants
usually it's the bigger producers that
are shifting to robusta
because the increase in yield is just
really affordable but he also told us
that
the only buyer in the region is nestle
and that presents a problem for the
farmers because they don't trust nestle
so
there's also been a lot of resistance to
this
and what nestle did was they introduced
four
clones of robusta that they figured were
optimized for production
but this makes the farmers really
skeptical because
they know that they're growing a lower
quality product
which they're not going to be able to
sell if nestle one day decides to leave
or just to not buy their coffee
we did meet this lovely man called fidel
lopez
also in the southern region of chiapas
and he has a completely different story
so
he used to grow conventional coffee and
when the coffee leaf rest hid his farm
in 2012. he decided he just couldn't
afford the pesticides so he was going to
let it go
and basically abandoned his farm for a
couple years and then he came back
and he saw his plans and the way he
tells the story is he found these
trees that just looked more beautiful
than ever
and so he harvested their seeds and
propagated them and started his coffee
plantation again
and he also decided that he was going to
grow
organic coffee because it was safer for
his family
so like i mentioned most of these small
holders have
farms that are maybe
four acres and their farms are on their
their houses are on them and their
children are playing there
so nobody wants to be spraying
pesticides constantly
so for a lot of these small holder
farmers the organic
certification has the appeal that they
feel like they're safer
and that they're taking care of their
little plot of land
he decided also that he was going to
start roasting his own coffee
and selling it and he teamed up with his
family and now the whole family runs
this
little company called cafe richilia
where they sell
the product that they grow and he says
that it's working out really well for
him
because he's actually making more money
and this is him showing us one of those
uh
wonderful trees that he claims has
become resistant to rust
he had at least three different
varieties of coffee
he had one that was produced by the
mexican
equivalent to the usda which was an
improved variety resistant to rust
but the others he had were the
traditional susceptible varieties and he
claims he has
absolutely no rust pressure in his farm
uh so one of the latest things that
is affecting coffee growers is
unfortunately
kovid and this is what the
colombian federation of farmers is doing
to try to keep people safe
they've taken their traditional logo and
transformed it
into on the left to keep social distance
and on the right to cover your mouth
when you sneeze
i was saying that colombia expects to
have
the best harvest ever in 2020
but obviously because
the coffee harvest is so labor intensive
they require a lot of migrant workers to
come in
and they actually move throughout the
whole country so
like i mentioned before coffee
blooms right after the rainy season and
because of the way the winds work in
colombia there's
very discreet rainy season that starts
at the beginning of the year in the
north
and then moves south along the andes
and then ends at the southern part of
the andes in colombia
at around october and then we'll
basically shift the rain
back north so the middle of the country
has two harvests
while the north and the south part have
one and there's this huge
body of migrant workers that just move
with the rains following the coffee
harvest
and obviously covet is a horrible risk
because not only are you putting these
people in risk they're just
literally moving it across
another big problem is that because
people are leaving the countryside for
the cities it's hard to find laborers
and that's one of the
surprising situations in which the very
sad
situation in venezuela has proved useful
for colombian coffee growers and that
venezuelans now make up a big chunk of
the migrant
labors that pick coffee
so anyway um that's all i have
i'm happy to take questions sorry for
the introduction the interruption i
don't even know what happened
but
i know where host is but uh i'm here so
i mean there are the questions for juan
one this is marvin it sounds like with
that narrow genetic diversity
uh the industry's crying out for a
breeding program for
expanding the diversity of the germplasm
so what's happening around the world
with breeding programs um lots of things
there's
well first of all there's uh
there's a lot of people who are
interested in the wild coffee species
in the forest of ethiopia and apparently
there's huge pressure on these forests
um so there's there's a lot of concern
that
the the source of all this genetic
diversity is being lost
because of you know a deforestation an
expansion of
of the agricultural boundaries and all
that stuff um
there is a research group from
texas that is working on producing f1
hybrids
which is something that coffee growers
at least
to my knowledge do not work with um
because because production costs are so
high
what most growers will do is they will
propagate their own plants
so you grab your seeds from your plant
from the good plants and then you
start your new plants if you're working
with an f1 hybrid
you need to you need to buy the seed and
that is going to
mean more costs for the computers so
i know that they're promoting this in
mexico and in guatemala
i haven't heard of an f1 hybrid project
program in colombia um
the fnc which is the colombian
coffee union they have a research
program and they've just released a new
variety
[Music]
they release varieties i think every
five years or so and they are
very very specialized and regionally so
they will
release their latest variety it's called
sunny cafe one
but they have a senica for the centers
and center
for ourselves so it's very specialized
in that sense
um there's also
some people will use rootstock but i've
only seen this in big plantations
you know 300 hectares or more
where they'll use the robusta rootstock
on arabica's scions and that seems to
work really well
for at least for disease pressure
um i know that they've developed um
a transgenic coffee for resistant to
the coffee bean borer but no one wants
to release that because that immediately
means you lose the european market and
no one's gonna buy it so that's a dead
end unfortunately
um yeah that's that's all i know of
thanks any other questions for juana
fascinating look at the
place that we don't generally get to so
i always enjoyed your
vlogs from uh columbia and wherever you
were
so i thank you very much for that i
think there's some questions on the chat
okay do you know why fair trade
guarantees 140
but growers get less than that
um yes so
coffee is really complex um a lot of
growers are really far away
basically and they need to bring their
coffee to
a on a copy of a
gathering uh a warehouse where everybody
brings their coffee yet to sell
right and some people
so the the values that i presented here
are what's called
value at farm gate so you have to
include transportation
and the further you are the more that is
going to cost
um in particular i can speak for
colombia the roads are terrible
and sometimes the distance might not be
too long but the road is so bad that it
takes you hours to get there
so that's a big chunk that gets taken
off the price
in addition most small holders will be
part of an organization and that
organization takes
its share too so even though the
organization sells the coffee for 140
they don't pay the growers 140. because
they need they have their own operating
costs and
whatever in in the case of these four
organizations that were considered in
this study
[Music]
at the end of the year they'll all get
together and they'll decide all right
how are we spending this extra money
that we got from fair trade
as their premium and they some will say
all right we want dividends or some will
say we want some sort of
um you know improvement project that
benefits the community so maybe
they'll build a school or they'll build
a processing plant or
something like that um yeah some people
find full fund extension agents some
people will
fund even scholarships for their members
so it depends a lot on what the
organization
wants and how they're structured um i
also know of
italy which is a big coffee seller in
europe
they also guarantee that they're there
they buy their coffee at 1 140. but
again
this value was they came up with it kind
of
out of nowhere because the cost of
production are really hard to estimate
um part of one of the smart programs
that i did was trying to
to come up with what is this cost of
production and and what we found is it's
really hard because a lot of
a rural economy is still very informal
so there are no receipts there's no
keeping track
farmers don't like to keep track because
they don't want to know how much money
they're losing
so it's it's a tricky situation and if
you're such a big organization as fair
trade which is in
every country and almost all crops
it's hard to come up with a baseline
cost that's going to help
everybody so i hope that answered the
question
there's another question have you heard
of any progress in the usda
coffee germ plasma collection to develop
release coffee germplasm with rust
resistance
and superior cupping quality
i have no idea about the usb coffee
collection i have to admit
i did hear that they found rust in
hawaii which is really sad
but that's all i know unfortunately
sorry
i have a question i was wondering um
this last picture here kind of looks
like a very diversified
farm um and i was wondering what you
think the future holds for doing more
regenerative types of agriculture where
more of the ground is actually covered
with crops or if you know the future
really holds
us cutting more and more of our rain
forest down
and what the irrigation schemes look
like especially as water becomes more
scarce as the water cycle is disrupted
that's a great question um so one of the
things that successful coffee farmers
are doing is diversifying
and not necessarily separating their
crops but
incorporating everything so as you can
see here there's pineapples and then the
foreground there's
banana trees and the coffee in the
middle um
that's that's a strategy that's proven
very successful
more than than for let's say ecosystem
services for
food security because a lot of
smallholder coffee farmers are very food
insecure
so a lot of organizations are promoting
diversification
as a strategy to increase food security
and then it comes with benefits of
better soil quality and other things in
terms of
more broader scale things there's
a couple of good examples of payments
for ecosystem services to coffee farmers
in costa rica
but they tend to miss the smallholders
it tends to be the bigger
farms that can afford to you know
dedicate half the farm
to forest and then get paid for that um
if you only have a couple of acres you
can't afford to not
farm at all because then you just don't
make enough money
um so from a research perspective
there is a big push for agroforestry
systems
in that you have a forest it serves up a
function
and you can select species that are are
valuable for wood for instance if you
have a bad coffee here you can cut down
your trees and sell them and you're not
going to
starve but it's it's hard because
until we start valuing the
ecosystem services such as carbon
sequestration
on a global level it's just not no one's
going to pay the farmer and if the
farmer doesn't get paid
then ultimately they're not they're not
successful they won't
they won't be sustainable
thank you i hope that answered the
question yeah it did
yeah really great presentation juana i
don't know where don went but i'm here
so uh
i just want to thank you for all your
work and uh
i hope you're still around we can talk
to you in person
and uh thank you so much i appreciate it
yeah thank you thank you committee
it's our pleasure
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu